he was looking for the
right way to offer this course and had
looked at a bunch of technologies
and none of them were exactly a good fit
so um there are quite a few uh solutions
out there that
are good for what they call mastery
learning
they deliver lectures videos you know
multiple choice questions
programming assignments to the student
until the student masters
a particular topic so i've done some
squares
the camera's trained on you at all just
talking about it right
yeah it's just so the more invasive yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so it's a one-way channel of you know
you have the professor you say you know
the professor knows the
answers to all the you know sort of
questions you have and we just
you know help you gain that knowledge
sort of sage in a little box
sage on the stage yeah so um
but you know entrepreneurship is not
taught that way right there is no
multiple choice question that would test
whether you're an entrepreneur
or at least we haven't found it yet none
that we know
so uh we thought you know is there any
way to do this online and i asked him
how he does that
in his stanford course but he teaches
this entrepreneurship course in stanford
which is pretty popular
uh you know to an audience of probably
less than 100 around 100
students uh every year and he told me
well there i get the students to come
form a team
each team works on their own project
they come give a presentation they get
feedback from their peers
they get feedback from mentors that i
find for them
and that's the you know that's the way
the course work
and then i thought well maybe we should
do that online
um so i initially suggested that i
commit a little bit time a little bit of
time
so actually i and my student committed
eight days
four weekends to him and said we will
put something together for you to
simulate this
um but what happened was that
but just a little time out so even this
you're sort of
you're doing programming like you're
sort of switching to right
right right yeah i haven't had like a
normal
did you ever have any background in
programming or like well my degree
is computer science and i used to code a
long time ago
uh so i had to actually you know sort of
you know learn a few things
but i thought it's a fun project and i'm
helping uh
you know a very good colleague
yeah and you know very good uh and you
know he's you know heart was in the
right place he really you know was
trying to teach as many people
uh as possible so i thought i'll i'll
help him out
and you know hopefully in the process i
learned something right
um so you know we put this thing
together
and then 80 000 people signed up for
this course
so this video sort of uh you know one of
those you know sort of
interesting you know people like sort of
you know there were people from serial
entrepreneur very experienced
entrepreneurs in silicon valley
all the way to you know kids in acura
ghana
who didn't have internet access at home
or at school
they would have to walk to an internet
cafe they sent us pictures from this
internet cafe
however they would you know sort of go
there and you know watch the lectures or
submit their assignments
a very diverse group of people we had
the students from
over 150 different countries in the
world
uh the you know in terms of in a sort of
uh distribution of you know gender
was actually almost an equal split
between you know male and female
very interesting people very energetic
very enthusiastic who really and i sort
of wanted to do something
so so one question so i've interviewed
amin and chuck for our work our book on
scaling
and one of the things i thought that was
really interesting we emphasized this in
the book
is so you got 80 000 whittled down some
you have these people all over the world
so
what do you do to make it so that they
feel accountable and obligated
because if you think about it these are
people you never met you're on
your work so what you do to build in
accountability and evaluation in such a
huge course
and then let's go to a demo because i
think it's almost like i think we should
show folks how it works
all right sure so the very first step of
this was that they put them into a small
teams
so you have accountability to an
immediate set of peers
uh i actually you know sort of wrote the
first you know
the clustering algorithm uh you know we
looked at the backgrounds of you know
what country they're from what language
they speak
what's their interest whether they want
to start a non-profit for-profit
and we try to put them into teams so
there's just research on what's the
composition of
effective startup teams it's best that
if they are close to each other but they
have a diverse background
like you match a business person to a
science person
definitely not uh um yeah so um
we put them into teams and then said uh
submit your assignments you know work
together uh submit individually or work
together stop me together
but every time a team of students
submitted something they were rating
each other
from bob was a no-show to he was
fantastic
he was the leader so you would
accumulate this rating
like variation in in how
um people rated each other oh yeah
absolutely so
this is not like one of those things
where everybody is above average you
actually got you got
no we got actually a very good uh and
actually it's no
it's not it's not like uh uh a normal
distribution
uh we actually get uh very fat tails in
a sense that it's closer
it's something between normal and
uniform okay okay um
so um you collect these ratings and then
the ratings would turn into a
reputation and this is all your public
rating among the 80 000 students in the
class yeah everybody
everybody else is right yeah so from the
very beginning and you know
you talk about this in your talk
actually i learned some of these later
uh this creating this culture of
accountability and transparency
is very important if you want to scale
up
uh the experience of a you know a
classroom that's of size you know 20
to a classroom that's software so the
brilliance of it which
which um brown and i really liked they
created a world where basically
they is the teachers did not have to
monitor everybody they
it was a self-monitoring system and and
so i thought that was brilliant so it's
sort of like a giving the work to the
customers in some ways
but but it makes it better for the
customer and it reduces
your just there's no way you could have
a big enough brain to keep track of 80
so i thought that was actually both well
let's go to a demo so
um we've been talking about it so real
quickly when
when did your company when you when did
you sort of move from this class to a
company and then let's show um
oh yeah absolutely so yeah if i fast
forward so the first course was started
it was actually
very successful the students formed
teams they worked on a whole bunch of
different projects
some of these projects turned into
companies
so at the end of the course we helped
them pitch to venture capitalists the
top 20 teams
they there was this team from bolivia
they couldn't even you know sort of
speak english very well they've managed
to find the venture capitalists who
couldn't speak
spanish they pitched in spanish some of
these companies got
funding and then you know sort of uh we
got
a lot of requests so we got a lot more
students and then we got a lot more of
my colleagues who wanted to offer
courses
and at the time since we wanted to do
this
uh somewhat independent from stanford so
we get
courses from stanford and other
universities
obvious started it as a uh you know
separator startup
so you know from somebody who writes
papers as you said i turn into somebody
who
thinks about entrepreneurship education
and very quickly becoming uh an
entrepreneur myself and
now you're only with ceo and by the way
just um
so i mean why don't you prepare the demo
but i just a comment about the stanford
engineering school
so for some universities it might be
sort of weird for a
professor to stop out to be an executive
but this isn't a great stanford
engineering tradition and just to give
you an example um
our well our ceo our president uh john
hennessey who was a guest in your class
actually
um john has uh has stopped out to be a
senior executive and started up
several times and is back to in fact the
lead board member on google
so uh for better or for worse uh the
stanford engineering school is a very
entrepreneurial class
and what i mean is doing is actually not
that unusual for
for our faculty and it is viewed as
something that we sort of all win
so so we want him to get his company
started and then to come back and be oh
yeah
um okay so let's let's go to demo
oh sure all right let's see
i'm going to sort this out oh
um so everyone can see my screen
all right so um uh the actually the
project
started as a stanford venture lab
project uh but
you know since the range of courses that
we are offering right now is broader
than entrepreneurship
we call it novo ad so it's on you know
novoad.com
courses entrepreneurship you can see the
entrepreneurship courses
and you know it's like you know range of
courses on
uh from you know how you start
how you start this startup how to lead
it how to become a star how to
pitch to a venture capitalist how to
finance it but
let me go to this uh stanford course
technology entrepreneurship
part 1 by chalk and
show you how it works so it's as we
mentioned
it's a free course anybody can take it
uh
it's so this version of the courses
started on september 16
two days ago and you know you can still
sign up uh
if you go to class
so it's um you know as soon as you log
in you know the the welcome and then you
can see the students who were active
today
uh the lecture that's posted the
announcements
uh the trending uh threads on the
site now let me do um since this course
is started only two days ago there isn't
much content let me go to a version of
the course that was offered a little bit
earlier
and show you one of the teams that was
that was formed
so this is the environment that we give
to a team of entrepreneurs
so this team is called empowered
e-patients
so they have a nice logo uh raise hell
and change the world
um as you know every team can sort of
they can
create their business model canvas so
fill out you know sort of articulate
what their business model
is they have a journal so when they you
know sort of
they have a workspace so they can
collaborate together
submit their assignments write uh you
know different
uh you know write down their ideas like
i like their logo
yeah and change the world
so let's look at one student profile so
since we are talking about the
accountability and transparency and you
know how that can be used for scaling up
this is student uh andrea downing
uh she is in washington dc
in the united states uh on novo it since
one year ago last activity about 24
hours ago
she has a team rank of five out of five
so she's a very good
student yeah uh you know it starts with
the
boyo the goal is to empower patients to
take control of their health
course profile details you know of her
interests
you can see all the submissions of the
students so whatever they have submitted
whether it's a business model whether
it's the review of someone else's
business model
whether it's um uh
you know uh presentation on that sort of
day we're going to submit to
a venture capitalist so actually at the
very end you can see
the students community activities so
this student has initiated
seven threads posted 44 replies received
52 votes has written four peer reviews
but it's actually a pretty
uh active and engaged student and and so
one thing i like about this you can see
when you look at the site
first of all it's very social either
there's a whole there's forums there's
all sorts of things to do
and and then the other thing is then you
didn't talk about this other part but
it's worth talking about
that uh that people would kind of get
kicked off of teams or they'd be
pressured
to leave teams when they were performing
right so the numbers went down till many
thousand people take it but
but one thing i like about this is is in
many ways it's more accountability than
in class where i have to watch 60 or 70
students
in this case they're all sort of keeping
track of one another so uh so it's
really been a pleasant surprise to me
and also
you you see um how sort of lovely it is
too i think that it's got
quite an aesthetically um nice um site
so you want to do any more in the demo
or do you want to sort of talk about
where your company's going what do you
want to do next
um so uh let me see um
actually probably i shouldn't do too
much of the demo because you know you
can actually go
if anybody can go check it out yourself
so i want to spend
too much time on the side as much as i
like it and think i spent
a lot of time uh but uh i'll probably
shouldn't so
here since you mentioned this is the uh
at the
close today so one of the things that we
do is that we interview
uh various uh leaders in the field on
behalf of the students
so students submit questions votes up
the best questions and then you know i
or someone else go and ask the question
so
we interviewed john hennessy and you can
see this on the
university yes university president and
they got a whole range of course with
questions
some of them were about online learning
and that's not surprising and there were
quite a few questions about
tech transfer and how stanford is has
been successful in tech transfer and a
lot of the startups
that started from stanford have been
successful and at the same time the
silicon valley environment
and you know sort of are you know i can
understand that there is a lot of demand
for it and our goal is to create
a virtual environment like the silicon
valley
using our entrepreneurship courses so in
a sense
um when we will talk about this when we
talk about the trends uh
you know the first step is to open up
access
and this is something that you know the
innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate program is also doing right
at the low cost
students all around the world can take a
course and
learn about entrepreneurship but then
the next step is to empower them
to help them have access to each other
help them
if they like you know sort of to form
teams to work on their own ideas to give
each other feedback
and to provide them with resources like
mentorship and others so that they can
about the platform is that you recruited
these mentors who would then sign up and
mentor teams
all around the world too that was
another sort of social aspect i just
i just couldn't believe that oh yeah
absolutely so we sent messages out
so some of the mentors were found by the
students but a lot probably
50 percent of the mentors we found
themselves we just sent messages to
people
and these were very busy ventures yeah
like yeah we had partners in sequoia
sign up as uh mentors under on the
program
and they were extremely uh generous with
their time and extremely uh helpful
so we had you know mentors who started
by saying i'm going to mentor one team
and ended up mentoring 10.
oh yeah everybody very clever and lost
control
right one of the people who's involved
in various courses around her
ended up like mentoring about six of
them right so
i guess the lesson is we just have to
create the right environment and help uh
our people find each other that's all
that we are doing and then you know they
learn from each other they help each
other they
actually uh uh you know start their own
uh
adventure so so maybe what you could do
i want to
um make sure since since our focus is on
entrepreneurship and innovation
um for this certificate in particular
but i i want to make sure
uh to just give people a sense so so
this was the
very first one and we'll talk some about
how you started your company
moving from just sort of you and for nas
and talk and you sort of have this
company now
but but give us a sense of how many
different places
and classes that uh that novo ad is
being used just to provide people to
test how much you've because it's only
been about a year
right it's been yeah it's actually uh
less than a year so i
started in january full time and then we
launched the course the the platform
the learning environment uh officially
in mid
april okay it's been you know it's like
not very long
yeah uh but fortunately we have i think
right now around 15 to 20 courses in
entrepreneurship we have around
uh half a million students wow
who are interested in entrepreneurship
alone from
all around the world so we have actually
a very big contingency from
latin america the biggest is the still
united states uh
uh the within uh the biggest resistant
california
but uh we are growing and making it more
global
yes uh so and the goal is to develop
this to
30 to 40 courses in entrepreneurship by
the end
of next year uh so hopefully that would
be a combination of
free courses certificate courses and
then uh
hopefully a master's program i'm using
your platform
for an online version which i'm sorry
isn't free
and a um and my in class the other way
that i use the platform is my students
form teams we grade them actually so in
my class i've got 60 in class students
and i'll give feedback to each student
and all 60 students can see my feedback
because
in the old days you know your professor
would just write on your paper and it
would be this private thing
and i also have to be careful because i
there were times when i said things like
early on i had to kind of control myself
we don't actually show the grades
because we think that's the privacy
issue
but in terms of the feedback that way
when people say what's a good or a bad
paper instead of saying oh
we've got to collect them it's go to the
site and look at the i'm kind of
feedback that we're giving
people so so for us it's actually very
convenient and i did have the experience
using your site
of uh of actually um sitting on an
airplane virgin virgin
airlines like flight 10c or something
and grading all my students papers on
the way
um on the way to boston the flight
started i got online and it was over i'd
actually graded all their papers
and that's where means platform was
fabulous and everybody and i had the
students complaining about about
the feedback i gave them online in the
airplane it was sort of like amazing
live interactive thing um so um
one one other question before we sort of
move to the process
of this of how the the startup is
unfolded and how you get getting there
so is this just a stanford event a
stanford platform are you moving out to
other universities what's going on
no we are actually now offering courses
from uh void you know sort of a lot of
universities
uh it's actually growing yeah uh so for
example one
in entrepreneurship babson college is
uh venture capitalists that the kaufman
fellow academy
is actually offering a few courses on
you know how to become a better vc and
also a few courses for entrepreneurs
how to pitch better or how to uh raise
money for your startup
uh there is uh so some of these are you
know we're going to announce
soon but let me at least do one of them
pre-announcement
yeah so the carnegie foundation for the
advancement of teaching
working together to develop a whole set
of courses
and yeah so carnegie foundation has been
uh looking at
online education and coming up with
better methods for engaging
students for over five years so
now we are trying to use some of those
uh learnings and apply them
i know they've done a lot of stuff in
community colleges i mean
that's one of the big pushes in the
kearney foundation is because
community colleges are such a backbone
of especially the u.s economy
that they're doing all this stuff to try
to make um education cheaper and better
in community colleges so that's
that's pretty pretty cool right yeah so
some of this is the community but
overall there are sort of these basic
principles that you know uh in
basic pedagogical models that we are
learning and trying to apply
you know in uh not just in courses that
are offered to community colleges but
uh to all courses uh but absolutely you
know the community colleges and sort of
for example this major math
problem oh yeah but these are some of
the problems that we are trying to
address
okay so i've got to talk to the adults
who are running this how much time do we
have left
15 minutes so do we have any any
interesting questions before we go on
and talk about the startup
because sometimes we would like to oh we
do so
uh and you may be getting to this one we
have we have one from
and i apologize if i mispronounced his
name i believe it's
santo rao and the question is what have
been the most
what have been the biggest challenges in
developing a business financial model
for noble ad
um so actually the you know the business
model or the revenue model is something
that we are working on
uh with our partners so uh one of the
you know sort of one of the
goals of novo ed is to find universities
and institutions who
like to expand and you know sort of have
a stronger presence
online and then uh our you know sort of
our business model is to do uh some form
of
uh revenue sharing with these partners
and go online so
um probably um uh
you know the sort of the one of the one
of the major challenges
is if you look at the university systems
you know they have a certain you know
time and you know
a certain way of doing things and then
in the startup world you definitely want
to be faster and more efficient
and you know bringing this synchronizing
these two clocks is not always easy
do you have sort of a software licensing
model would that be
at least your initial business model or
what's what's it sort of
like no but you know it's not a
licensing model in a way that we don't
actually
charge universities uh upfront fee
we help them scale up or we help them
increase their retention
increase their uh you know the
completion okay and
uh sort of uh so sort of recharge them
after the you know the result of our
work is seen that's actually a great
transition question
because um uh now we're gonna move to
entrepreneurship any any other stuff
especially on entrepreneurship or
i can start asking to mean some some
general sort of
entrepreneurship questions i was curious
about but um
if you've got another question it's
great it's great hearing from folks who
are actually watching instead of me just
ranting it i mean
it sounds to me that you may be asking
or answering this question next to the
the follow-up question that was uh
what has been your process for solving
uh the
for the your business challenges so
i'm not sure if that's going to be part
of it yeah yeah let's let's let's go on
okay so
so um so in this process so it's sort of
you and
your student and you're trying to work
with facts but
so how do you just sort of build the
team and create this
the kind of social network so he can
turn this sort of idea into a company
since
i mean that's a big issue for a lot of
entrepreneurs they kind of got an idea
and you actually had a product which
surprised some of the local veteran
athletes you talked to
oh he's got a product works already
right that's pretty good yeah
but but so how did you make that
transition so you're actually you've got
a company people sit together
yeah absolutely so how did you get there
right
so i think um i would say for your sort
of future entrepreneurs uh
the most important step is committing
yourself
so when you develop when you take the
leave of absence when you start on you
know day one
monday you show up in the office it's
you and your co-founder
and you're committed you're full-time
getting the third person is a lot easier
then when you have you know sort of a
few other things going on and you know
this may look like a project that you
like a little bit
you know you may start you may build on
it you may not
so i i would say that the most important
thing that i
did that was helpful that helps with the
growth of the company was committing
uh uh full-time to it okay so so
you committed full time to it which is i
mean you've got a
teaching responsibility so you take a
leave right then when you start building
out the team
who would you look for like what what do
you need to be successful
in in your space because that next step
from
two to sort of seven or eight is in in
entrepreneurship we
think of big companies but that that
initial step lots of evidence
two to seven or eight one of the most
important providers
right so we actually looked for
talent raw talent in a sense that you
know we didn't look for
skill sets to say i need a you know ruby
on rails program
to program it tomorrow because i need
this part to be written
we tried to look for people who were you
know have very strong analytical
abilities who were
hardworking who were super smart and
then at the same time uh
i you know i can't quote your uh uh the
name of your book but you know sort of
the people who are not jerks
uh yeah
yeah so you know yeah exactly so we want
to make sure that
uh you know it's the group of people
that they can work together
so we have this operating principle
when we are designing the site and
that's about empowerment
right so if you look at the site in a
sense it says you know education is not
about
it's not a one-way channel for uh you
know sort of transferring content you
have to actually empower the learner
you have to uh you know give them an
identity help them actually find
what they are looking for we are and uh
sort of
fosters skills like uh critical thinking
uh collaboration uh and uh communication
you're eating your own dog food exactly
so we are trying to apply this to our
own company as well i mean just
for folks on entrepreneurship um and
this applies to innovation too
for for company growth there's kind of
two
basic philosophies and you can even see
this in very large companies if you
compare apple to google for example
um there's some companies from the very
beginning they want
super specialists who are the absolute
best thing in the world at this
at this narrow thing and then there are
other companies that focus
for sort of all around players who can
sort of grow their responsibilities with
the company so it sounds like you're
going
to the latter the more googly sort of
model instead of the more
model yeah so our model is to hire
various smart people and then try to get
out of their way down micromanage
that works um so um
oh ryan's got a look on his face yes
yeah bring it on
so there's a couple of questions that
are around funding and if you could
maybe just speak shortly to how you
funded this this
entre your adventure oh sure so uh
with one thing actually uh we have been
lucky
uh so there has been a lot there you
went to like a million meetings you were
right amazing how many people you met
with right yeah like somebody just came
and gave them money
there was a lot of talk there but there
was a lot of yeah so you know for a
certain period
i would talk to anybody who would talk
to me in a sense for
for two or three weeks i had quite a few
meetings
uh so what we came up with and i got an
advice was you know sort of decide what
you want
communicate this effectively very
clearly in the very first meeting
and you know come up with a timeline so
that's what we did i you know sort of
i went around talk to a few people give
them a sort of you know this is what we
are looking for
and uh ask them to send me uh you know a
heads up
if they are interested so fortunately
the interest we got
into the company was uh you know five or
six times more than what we actually
were anticipating um
to raise so we had to actually you know
change a few things a few parameters
with a little bit more money
uh involve more people but um sort of uh
the model was come up with a come up
with this you know sort of
your pitch talk to a lot of people and
be very clear about what you want
great um so any other
questions besides besides the the money
part i'd be curious about about the uh
because i think we've talked about that
enough
other aspects of the team were running
the organization so there were a few
we will have time for we will have time
for question and answers after
uh one of the things that i think are
interesting is we have kind of what's uh
maybe the number one lesson that you
learn about becoming an entrepreneur
from
being non-technical well you are
technical but going into being an
entrepreneur
uh so that i think that's an interesting
question that we have and the other one
that
i think is also very relevant is the one
where it says somebody who wants to be
an entrepreneur
and also work a full-time job as you
were doing as a professor
um so the number one lesson i learned
was that it's a lot of work
you know it's a serious thing it's sort
of uh you know this is among friends and
sort of indiana academy can you forget
something it's almost you know sort of
cute but you know you're not minded
professor it's not a big deal
but then when you're an entrepreneur
somebody has to get the paycheck a day
in a sort of uh
you can't really forget things you have
to you know
david kelly is a professor and also
an entrepreneur always says it's
stanford i can do what i want but in my
company
these people have families to feed right
it's a different yeah so it's sort of
you know 20 30 40 different kinds of
responsibilities
and you can't really let you know any of
these balls fall
so you have to be on our you know sort
of all the time
okay that's interesting i if you want to
go ahead and continue
let's go in a little bit so so so how
much more time do we have before we
go five minutes okay so so let's let's
sort of step back
and do some of the big pictures so you
kind of got so how many how many
people are actually in your company
where it's actually a small company
eight
so that's not critical eight people you
guys you gotta deal with personalities
there's a lot of evidence the team size
mostly my team has to deal with my
personality
well at least you're trying to be worse
so um um
so so you've sort of reached about eight
but
so where do you see the next few steps
for your company and then and then i
want to talk about
the crazy online ed space since i know
you have some ideas about that but
right kind of give us where do you think
you folks are going for the next year
like like in terms of growth and scaling
and
stuff yeah i still i just you know sort
of i used to lose the sleep over you
know what if nobody wants this
now we have actually found a few
partners who want to grow significantly
using our technology
but now i'm losing a slip over you know
how are we going to deliver uh
so we're going to have i'm not i'm
worried about demand to worry about
dealing with the debate
yeah that's not so bad yeah that's not
so much yeah that's a good problem to
have
but what it means is that over the next
year they're going to actually scale up
faster
okay and you know uh in that sense uh we
have to you know try to make sure that
we
continue to apply these lessons on you
know sort of how to scale up but
maintain excellence
uh in uh in the company so you must
spend
so you're spending a lot of time hiring
and so i know you're down
um in the sort of palo alto mello parker
and you say we moved to the city
last week yeah congratulations that's
the new hip place to have a startup is
in the city so that's pretty good yeah
so okay um so i'm glad that things are
progressing and
and to me how going from worried about
getting customers to having um
uh you know so many you have to worry
about how to handle them is an excellent
sort of problem
the problem is it's uh something that
every startup needs
but let's sort of back up because you
you've been even though in the sort of
moog online education
space uh you've been doing it for about
a year and a half or two right you get
on half yeah
so this means he's actually way ahead of
the curve of most places
so what have you learned about what
makes it effective
and the way that things might and should
go in the future
because this is something every
university every company is worrying
about this right
right um so i think you know if you look
at the
you know sort of the early the first
generation of solutions new
solutions that came up with and they
were some of them are very popular
uh the popularity shows more the you
know sort of the symptoms of the
uh yeah and they're they're not
necessarily a solution
to online education to to edu or you
know higher education
so what i'm expecting is that you know
given that there are more and more
courses coming online content becomes
more and more commoditized in a sense
that uh uh
you know like you know if right now if
you want knowledge if you just want
answer to your question there are a lot
of
places where you can go and uh you know
find your dance such as social now
another part of the education is the
intellectual stimulation all right so
actually one of my colleagues used to
say you know
education is what you take with you when
you forget the
actual material right so you know sort
of i actually like to talk about
forces critical thinking creativity
um critical thinking creativity
collaboration and communication skills
these are the if you go to college these
are the four skills
that call 21st century skills that you
foster that you sort of uh
um and
our goal is that in this transition from
beacon mortar to online learning
we don't lose these things we actually
find
a way to use the social web to amplify
it
to make sure that the students get that
and i think that's going to be the
critical piece that's going to be the
part that sort of technology
so it is interesting because there's
been this sort of movement and i see
this in my own classes i see it in my
kids high school classes where they
start having the flip model where they
actually
receive the um the information online
but the purpose of the class is to
actually have social interaction
so so that so we're seeing that happen
but the perspective you're talking about
is actually
more subtle which is that if you've got
a class
in your case thousands of people who
never met each other and may not meet
each other
still to make it an emotionally
satisfying and social
experience that gets is that i mean
that's and to me that's the great thing
about your platform and your goal
too right absolutely so in in fact uh a
lot of these massive open online courses
have a very low completion rate partly
because it's just a boring experience to
watch video after video or
sort of interact with uh with your
computer but if you're interacting with
other people online
uh that's you know sort of that's that's
a different uh
story uh that that creates a you know
whole different
experience so these are the things that
we are actually building on
uh in terms of trends i think actually
online education is going to grow
it's here to stay it's going to and uh
partly because
of the you know because of the scale of
the classes that we are offering we are
you know we learn things faster and we
get better
uh so we get you know every time we
offer a course every time we give a team
assignment
we learn a little bit more about which
team compositions are better
uh we learn a little bit more about you
know whether you know this person you
know this particular student is going to
show up
even uh to this you know team
affirmative so i mean
this sort of this is where big data can
actually help uh
online education let's talk about how
that how big data can help online
because you hear this word big data all
the time how does it actually help
online education
right so you know teaching used to be
something that we do
in a classroom behind closed doors
right one person would show up in front
of their students
talk to them they learn something then
you're sort of
they're gone and then if some teachers
do it better some teachers do it
worse but there is really no way of
measuring learning outcomes there is no
way of figuring out what works and what
doesn't and then
the lessons are not exchanged uh between
the you know instructors within the fact
that this is not what we
discussed in a faculty meeting right
right oh so
uh but when you do this online and then
you're actually
measuring everything you can actually
get better you can actually see what
works and what doesn't work and you can
see this at a massive scale
so when you're offering of course an 80
000 people take it
you can actually you know the signal is
separated from the noise you can
actually
find effects you can see patterns yeah
very interesting and you know you can do
a b testing you can uh
uh you know sort of observe students at
a granular level and also at a scale
and you know those findings we try to
transfer them back to the instructor
or you know find ways of hearing from
working with
your team just for my classes this week
like i'm getting feedback no don't do
that that's not gonna work try this but
it'll work better so right so i think
that's
kind of weird so that's one of your
roles is i mean besides uh helping
people with the technology
is is you kind of going into the
advisory business because
you you want everybody to use your
platform of the best possible
absolutely so it tries to transfer some
of this back to that
service
great guys so we had one question um
about how do you deal uh how do you turn
resistance
um or any type of hardship that you come
in or any negative feedback into a
positive
and overcome those issues that's a good
question that's a good question
ah well you know uh we are in a very new
space
so any comment positive or negative i
see it as a you know learning
opportunity
we really don't claim that we have
answers uh to most of the questions we
are there to learn and we are there to
learn fast
so any feedback is good for us i think
actually then you know the unfortunate
event is when nobody cares enough to
tell you something
when somebody cares enough about your
product to come and tell you
that this particular thing about it is
wrong
you actually have to uh you know sort of
uh uh
you know thank your lucky stars but they
actually you know like it enough they
want to use that and then they have
difficulties
so uh negative feedback it's actually a
good thing you know you you want to hear
it
yeah yeah i mean that's excellent um so
that's an interesting question also
because in some ways
your argument is that the uncertainty in
silence is much worse
than negative feedback
but when you get no feedback then you
get the right it gets indifferent
yeah that's really interesting because
the whole entrepreneurship process and
frankly
since since the mean is been a career
academic we get so much negative
feedback on our work
we're just used to it right yeah i mean
if you do something good nobody comments
that means that
either they don't care or nothing's
wrong with it but we live for
negative respect so academics are well
suited to this it's also
uh when you have jeremy and perry
involved we'll talk about the notion
that that
essentially negative feedback building
things that don't work
that's that's the whole key to the
entrepreneurship and creative process
is is failing forward and you're always
failing the question is how quick are
you learning
and we have time for uh just one last
question we received variations actually
of this question from a lot of the
participants that were online
they were asking what is the number one
piece of advice you would give
for somebody that has an idea and wants
to get started
take this course take a technology
entrepreneurship course that's actually
about you know how you turn
an idea how to test it out how to see
whether there is a market for it
and uh then maybe you can you know find
the team and you can actually
start working on it what about the
number two piece of advice
that was a commercial but it was a good
yeah
i mean when you think because and you've
been through this in the last year
i mean you talked about commitment but
but what what about
you know just sort of like the personal
advice and sort of information
personally
yeah so personal idea and sort of uh and
this is something i have learned from
church and others now who teach this is
to test it out
build a minimum viable product and try
to test it
with the users uh so you know there are
a lot of interesting ideas out there the
question is who is going to actually
refine it and who's going to actually
face the people who are going to be the
consumers
and make turn it into something that
people actually want so this is really
quite interesting
maybe this is a good point to end
because this is to me the point where
creativity
meets entrepreneurship and a little bit
of big data too because
creativity's sort of iteration coming
with all these crazy ideas
but where you can actually turn into a
viable product is when
you're moving forward at all times and
if
you hear what amine is talking about
they're using well
people giving specific feedback but also
by looking at the evidence from their
big data
how many people are taking your classes
now see that number again for half a
million
so so they can in addition to the things
people say they can see their behaviors
and learn what succeeds and what doesn't
and keep moving forward so this notion
that everything is a prototype
and you're always sort of moving forward
that's one of the themes that runs
throughout all entrepreneurship all the
courses we're teaching at stanford
whether it be the certificate program or
anything else
so maybe that's a good place to enter so
you become a serious prototyper but you
but you use big data too
i like that combination of those too all
right so thank you so much for joining
our website
thanks for having me it's always a
pleasure to talk to you
um it wasn't a very private conversation
but it was fun yeah absolutely
on behalf of the stanford center for
professional volunteer i want to thank
both of you we really appreciated it and
it seems
from the interaction every our audience
did too for those of you who are able to
join us again we appreciate having you
today uh we will be sending out the link
to the
to the recorded webinar within a week so
if you missed any part or want to replay
it
you'll have that opportunity
you